so the book
is uh as a memoir is about your life and
it
uh weaves both your fascination
with planets outside the solar system
and the path of your life
and you lost your husband which is
a kind of central part of the book
that created a feeling of the rogue
planet
by the way what's the name of the book
the name of the book is
the smallest lights in the universe
what's up with the title what's the
meaning the title has a double meaning
on the face of it it's the search for
other earths earths are so dim compared
to the
big bright massive star beside them
searching for the earth's
is like searching for the smallest
lights in the universe
it has this other meaning too i really
hope that you
or the other people listening never get
to the place
where you're just you've fallen off the
cliff into
this horrible place of huge despair
and once in a while you get a glimmer of
a better life of some kind of hope
and those are also the smallest lights
in the universe well maybe
we can tell the full story
before we talk about the glimmer of hope
um what did it feel like
uh to first find out that your husband
mike was sick
it was incredibly frustrating like lots
of
us have had some kind of problem that
the doctors
completely ignore just that they kept
blowing him off it's nothing
are they paid to just say something i
mean it's just insane
it's just so angry and we finally got to
a point where he was really sick he
was like in bed not able to move
basically
and it turned out all the things they
ignored and not done any tests he had
like a 100 blockage in his intestine
like 100 like nothing could get out
nothing could get in
and it was pretty pretty shocking to
even hear then that it could be nothing
what was the progression of it in the
context of the maybe the medical system
the doctors i mean what did it feel like
did you feel like a human being uh
i felt like a child like the doctors
were trying to
water down the real diagnosis or treat
us like we couldn't know the truth or
they didn't know
you know i felt mixed like it's not a
good situation if you think the doctor
either has no idea what he or she is
doing
or if the doctor is purposely let's just
say lying to you to sugarcoat it
like i didn't know which one of it was
but i knew it was one of those
what were what were the things he was
suffering from
well initially he just had a random
stomachache i hate to say that out loud
because i know a lot of people
will have a random stomachache but so he
just had a bad stomachache and then hmm
this is weird
a few days later another bad stomachache
kind of gets worse might go away for a
few weeks might come back
and at the time all i knew was my dad
had that same thing
not the same identical system but he had
these really weird pains and he
ended up having the worst diagnosis one
of the worst diagnoses you can get from
a random stomachache is pancreatic
cancer
because the time the pancreas like you
can't feel anything so by the time you
feel pain it's too late it's spread
already
so i was just like beside myself i'm
like this is like wow this guy he's a
random stomach ache all i know is
another man i loved had a random
stomachache and it didn't end well
how did you deal with it emotionally
psychologically
intellectually as a scientist what was
that like
that that whole because it's not
immediate it's a it's a long journey
it's a long journey and you don't know
where the diagnosis is going
so anyone who's suffered from a major
illness there's like always
branches in the road so you know he had
this intestinal blockage
i can't imagine someone in their 40s
having that and that be normal
but the doctor is like it could be
nothing could just cut it out you don't
need most of your intestine it's a
repeating pattern
just cut that out it could be fine but
it ended up not being fine and he was
diagnosed as being terminally ill
well it really changed my life in a huge
way first of all
i remember immediately one summer the
summer when this happened
i started asking everyone i knew i would
ask you i know it's my job to put you on
the spot
i'd say you have one year to live or two
or three
what will you do differently about your
life now
lex you have one year to live what would
you do
i mean it's hard i don't know if you
want to answer no no no i think about it
a lot i mean
that's a really good thing to meditate
on we can talk about
maybe how uh while you bring that up
what if it is or not a heavy question
but
i get uh i i think about mortality
a lot and
for me it feels like a really good
way to focus in on is what you're doing
today
the people you have around you the
family you have
is it uh
does it bring you joy does it bring you
fulfillment
and basically
uh for me i've long ago
tried to be ready to die any day
so like today i you know i kind of woke
up look if i was nervous about talking
to
um i've i really admire your work
and the book is very good and super
exciting topic
uh but then you know there's this also
feeling like
if this is the last conversation i have
in my life you know if i die
today will this be let's be uh the right
like am i glad today happened and it is
and i
am glad today uh happened so that that's
the way
and that's so unique i never got that
answer from a single person
the busyness of life there's goals
there's dreams there's like planning
plans very few people make it happen
that's what i learned
and so a lot of these people oh like you
run out of time
it's not so much you have time but i'd
come back later and be like okay why
don't you do that
if that's what you would do if you're
gonna die a year from now why don't you
why don't you make it real simple things
spend more time with family
like why don't you do that and no one
had an answer it turns out unless you
usually unless you have
you really do have a pressing end of
life people don't do their
bucket list or try to change their
career and some people can't so we can't
like for a lot of people
they can't do anything about it and
that's that's fine but the ones who can
take action for some reason never do and
that was one of the ways that
mike's death or at the time his
impending death really really affected
me
because you know for these sick people
what i learned he had a bucket list and
he was able to do some of the bucket
lists it was awesome
but he got sick pretty quickly so if you
do only have a year to live
it's ironic because you can't do you
can't do the things you wanted to do
because you get too sick too fast what
were the bucket list things
for you that you realize like what am i
doing with my life
that was the major con of him after he
died i didn't know
like i i was just lost because when
something that profound happens
all the things i was doing um most of
the things i was doing were just
meaningless
it was so tough to to find an
answer for that and that's when i
settled on i'm to devote the rest of my
life
to trying to find another earth and to
find out
to find that we're not alone
what is that longing for connection with
others um
what's that about what do you think why
is that so full of meaning
i don't know why i mean i think it's how
we're hardwired like one of my friends
some time ago
actually when my dad died he
never heard someone say this before but
he's like sarah you know
why are we evolved to take death so
harshly
like what kind of society would we be if
we just didn't care people died
like that would be a very different type
of world how would we as a species
have got to where we are so i think that
is
tied hand in hand with why do we why do
we seek connection
it's just that we were talking about
before that subconsciousness that we
don't understand
yeah coupled you know the other side the
flip side of the coin of
connection and love is a fear of loss
it's like that was again i don't know
that's what makes you appreciate the
moment
is that the thing ends yeah it's
definitely a hard one
the thing ends but and it's hard to not
you
you wouldn't want to limit like it's
like my dog who i love so much i'll
start to cry like i can't think about
the end i know he'll age much faster
than i will
and some date will end right but it's
too sad to think of
but should i not have got a dog right
should i have not brought this sort of
joy
into my life because i know it won't be
forever it's
well there's a there's a philosopher
ernest becker who wrote a book denial of
death
and just uh and warm of the cores and
there's another book
talks about terror management theory
sheldon solomon i just
talked to him a few weeks ago
he's a brilliant philosopher
psychologist that
their theory whatever you make of it is
that
the fear of death is at the core of
everything
everything we do so like you're
that you think you don't think about the
mortality of your dog
but you do and that's what makes the
experience rich
like there's this kind of like in the
shadows lurks
the the knowledge that this won't last
forever
and that makes every moment just special
in some kind of uh weird way that it the
moments are special for us humans
i mean sorry to
use romantic terms like love but
what do you make what did you learn
about love from
from losing it from losing your husband
well i learned to love the things i have
more
i learned to love the people that i have
more
and to not let the little things bother
me as much
what about the rediscovery
or like the discovery of the little
lights
in the darkness so you the book
i think you uh brilliantly describe
um the dark parts of your journey
uh but maybe
can you talk about how you were able to
rediscover the lights
they came in many ways and the way like
to think about it is like
grief is an ocean with tiny islands
of the little like like the little
lights and eventually
that ocean gets smaller and smaller and
the islands like become continents with
lakes
so initially it'd be like the children
laughing one day
or my colleagues at work who rallied
around me
and would take me away from my darkness
to work on a project
later on it turned out to be a group of
women my age
all widows all with children in my town
and it would be even though it was a bit
morose getting together
still very joyful at the same time
what was the journey of rediscovering
love
like for you so refining i mean
is there some by way of advice or
insight about how to um
how to rediscover the beauty of life of
life
it's a hard one i think you just have to
stay
open to being positive and just to get
out there
do you still think do you still think
about your immortality
so you mentioned that that was a thing
that you would meditate on as a question
when it was right there in in front of
you but do you still think about it
i think i will after talking to you but
no it's not really something i think
about i mean i do think about
the search for another earth and will
will i get there will i be able to
conclude my search and is there one
like as time goes by you know that
window to solve that problem gets
smaller
what would bring you again i apologize
if this makes concrete the fact that
life is finite but
what um what would bring you joy if we
discovered
while you're still here will bring me
joy finding another earth an earth
like planet around a sun-like star
knowing that there's at least one or
more out there
being able to see water that it has
signs of water and being able to see
some gases that don't belong
so i know that the search will continue
after i'm gone
enough to fuel the next generation ah
so just like opening the door and
there's like this glimmer of hope
what do you think it will take to
realize that i mean we've talked about
all these interesting projects starshade
especially
but is there something that you're
particularly kind of
uh hopeful about in the next 10 20 years
that might give us
that that exact glimmer of hope that
there's earth like planets out there
i have to i stand behind star shade in
all cases so
but there is this other kind of field
that i that everyone is involved in
because star shade is hard
earths are hard but there are there's
another category of
planet star type that's easier and these
are planets
orbiting small red dwarf stars they're
not earth-like at all think like earth
cousin instead of earth twin
but there's a chance that we might
establish that some of those have water
and signs of life on them
that's nearer term than star shade and
we're all working hard on that too
you